Speaker 1: Earlier in the show I told you
all of the ways in which this protracted fiasco
in the House of Representatives wherein Republicans
have been unable to elect a speaker is bad
for Republicans.
Now, that's good.
That makes me happy.
I think the Republican Party is terrible for
the country.
I think their goals and ambitions are destructive.
I want them to have a quagmire and to be unable
to push forward their disgusting agenda.
However, I don't want the country to fail.
And as a general principle, not having a House
speaker is bad for the country and it's a
national security risk and it is a source
of instability on the bulwarks.
Joe per token Republican wrote an article
touching on some of these issues called The
House is Paralyzed without a speaker creating
national security risks and a shadow shut
down.
Imagine if this impasse were occurring in
a presidential inaugural year.
And Joe, very precisely and astutely points
out all of the different ways in which this
current status quo is very bad, including
that no one has actually been sworn in to
the House of Representatives yet, even though
George Santo said he was sworn in, he wasn't.
And we'll get to that a little bit later.
And I think it's important just to be clear
about the risks that this presents.
It is, I would argue, even simpler than Joe
Per Tacconi lays out.
It's not that he's wrong, but it's even simpler.
This situation in the House where no one has
been sworn in and there is no speaker, it
can lead to a functional breakdown of the
House of Representatives.
The speaker actually plays a critical role
in managing and organizing the legislative
process and with no speaker.
How does the House conduct business and pass
legislation?
Is it possible to do?
It is, but it's significantly more of a mess
within government.
No speaker and no one sworn in.
Causes uncertainty.
It causes instability.
The speaker is one of the most powerful and
influential figures or positions in Congress,
and the American confidence in government
is certain to decline.
The our perception of the ability of the House
to govern is quite low, accurately, because
this is what they're doing.
And then you say, okay, fine.
That's that's that's abstract.
But in practical terms, what could that mean?
Well, it can lead to gridlock or inaction
on important issues.
When you think about debt ceiling votes or
if there is a natural disaster of some kind,
a crisis, an emergency, the need for funding
in a specific place, way or form without a
speaker and without a sworn in house, it is
significantly more difficult for the House
to actually manage those things, to respond
to unforeseen events.
And at the end of the day, to protect the
country's interests.
Now, do I think that Republicans don't care
about that?
No, I think at the individual level, a lot
of these Republicans would honestly say, no,
I do care about that.
I understand that I'm concerned.
Does that mean they should compromise on their
principles to the extent that this situation
is caused by or catalyzed by their principles?
No, I'm not saying that.
But we have to be factual.
We have to be honest.
We have to be realistic.
The longer this goes on, the more instability
is accurately perceived by the American people.
And obviously, the longer it goes on, the
higher the chances are that something could
happen domestically, internationally, and
in other ways that would require, in normal
circumstances, the involvement of the House
of Representatives.
And they will then be chaotically scrambling
to try to get involved, help or do something
about it.
So.
The primary interest from.
We have we have conflicting interests here.
Each faction of the Republican Party wants
to reign supreme in terms of ultimately deciding
who is going to become speaker of the House.
I get that.
That's politics.
They don't want to be seen as the losers.
They don't want to be seen as the ones who
were impotent in trying to impose their preference
of speaker.
That's one area.
The impact on the Republican Party we've already
talked about.
On the other hand, I hope that I'm accurate
in assessing that the
interest of the American people is to not
have to think about the House of Representatives.
And what I mean by that is, yes, there are
some people who are more politically engaged
than others who pay attention to.
When are the midterms?
Where is control of the Senate?
Where is control of the House and are more
involved in that, including people like those
who listen to this program, who watch our
clips?
The vast majority of the country, even many
of those who vote in the midterms, don't spend
their days and nights thinking about this
stuff.
And so it's sort of like referees in a in
a sporting event, if you're noticing the referees,
if you're thinking about the referees, if
the referees are significantly present in
the game, arguably it is because they are
doing something wrong or too involved or whatever
the case may be.
You've heard these sports analogies before
and likewise, I would argue if the American
people are thinking about the chaos in the
House of Representatives to the extent that
it has been front and center for the last
two or three days, it is a it is a bad thing.
It is the type of thing where we shouldn't
really have to be thinking about it.
The house
is there.
There's a natural disaster.
They're going to act.
They're going to they're going to help.
They're going to fund.
And that's where the national security risk
comes here.
We now have a balancing, a coming together
of how long are they willing to continue this
and how tolerant will the American people
be before approval rating, not only for the
House as a body where the approval rating
is always low, but approval for their individual
members of Congress is going to plummet?
I don't know the answer to that, but I'm guessing
we're going to start finding out about that
very, very soon.